full demand for fossil fuels is soaring
and co2
at worrying at worrying levels amidst
the gloom
the uk has set out dynamic new pledges
on climate ambition
as recommended by the committee on
climate change which advises the
government
how to get to net zero that's a huge
step forward
but it also needs to be delivered so we
need the government now to put in place
a package of measures a package of
ambitious
policies right across the economy that
will drive us to that kind of outcome
so far the government has made good
progress on decarbonising power
take today when just under a third of
our electricity came from renewables
like wind and solar but
environmentalists
say other sectors like transport and
agriculture are lagging
and the policies don't match the
ambition they can't get away with
chancellors not coming up with truly
green
carbon cutting budgets or transport
departments who are prepared to
go on the biggest road building program
for a generation
it's not just the government which needs
to adapt to the challenges of climate
change
the uk's promise to set itself up as a
global leader on the climate will mean
big changes for all of us and it should
be good for businesses like this
but in reality the policies are not
matching up to the ambition
natalie rusch runs an insulation
business in birmingham
high energy use in our buildings has to
be cut if climate targets are to be
reached
but she says a green scheme launched by
the government to offer financial
incentives to homeowners
to make improvements was chaotic now
we've actually started our first batch
of jobs but we've now got another
problem
in that we're finding it hard to get
paid because the paperwork
is quite extensive and understanding
different processes is
also you know another learning curve so
we've really
only just got off the ground with this
scheme and already it's ended
for the first time the targets will
include emissions from aviation and
shipping
the whole package is designed to give
boris johnson and the uk
real authority ahead of a critical year
of climate discussions
but the promises will have to be matched
with action if the rest of the world is
to be impressed enough
to follow suit lisa holland sky news